échapperéchapperu régime au rég.
- Ces re- Ces reouvailletrouvaii
si familsi familères seières set
impossibimpossibs il y ales il .
Tyson MaTyson Main a étértin a é
en Afghaen Afghastan en nistan m
Azizi étAzizi étt son inait son.
L'été d L'été dnier, loernier,s
tensionstensionse sont i se son,
Tyson saTyson sait que Hvait qum
allait dallait denir uneevenir e
pour lespour lesalibans. talibaé
ciel et ciel et rre pourterre pr
qu'il puqu'il puse avoirisse ava
et fuir et fuir boul.Kaboul.
"Hakim s"Hakim scachait e cacha,
raconte raconte ancien ml'ancie,
et il atet il atndait d'tendaitr
une occaune occaon de sesion deà
l'aéropol'aéropo, mais trt, maii
vite qu'vite qu' jour, jun jour:
Vas-y, fVas-y, fppe à lrappe à t
espéronsespéronsue ça fo que ça"
"Quand  "Quand us sommenous so,
des milldes millrs de iers de ps
se ruaiese ruaie sur lesnt sur ,
nous n'anous n'ans pas évons pas
de francde francr la porhir la ,
expliqueexpliqueakim. Hakim.
Après  Après ois tenttrois ten,
l'interpl'interpète et rète et e
ont finaont finament pu lement r
dans le dans le rnier voderniern
à quittà quitt Kaboul,er Kabouls
n'ont pan'ont paeu cettes eu ce.
"Nous a "Nous ans un auvons une
avec quiavec quious somm nous s,
mais il mais il t dans uest danp
de réfugde réfugs à Isliés à Isc
ses cinqses cinqnfants d enfant"
déplore déplore son.Tyson.
"Nous n "Nous nurions p'aurionr
notre minotre miion en Assion en
sans cessans cesens, ils gens, s
leur vieleur vien danger en dans
et maintet maintant nousenant ns
derrièderriè. Je ne re. Je ne m.
Pour moiPour moion ne la, on nes
un frèun frè derrière derriè."r"
Le Cana Le Cana s'est eda s'esé
à accueà accuelir 40 0illir 40 .
Jusqu'àJusqu'àaintenan maintenat
arrivés;arrivés;0 000 da 10 000e
d'un prod'un proamme humgramme e
et plus et plus  7000 dade 7000n
programmprogrammréservé e résers
qui ont qui ont dé le Caaidé le.
CHRIS CHRIS EXANDER,ALEXANDER,nn
ambassadambassadr can. eeur cann
- On n'é- On n'éit pas rtait pas
notre ponotre potique rélitiquer
prévenirprévenire retour le rets
et tout et tout  monde..le monde
monde, tmonde, ts les paous lest
participparticipà cetteé à cettn
devraiendevraienassumer t assumt
de la rede la reonsabilisponsab.
- Pour l- Pour lncien am'ancienr
canadiencanadienn Afghan en Afg,
le Canadle Canada le da a le dor
d'en faid'en fai plus.re plus.
- On dev- On devit viserrait vir
au Canadau Canadau moinsa au mos
100 000 100 000 ghans.Afghans.
- C'est - C'est airementclairem.
- Et l'o- Et l'oosition ppositie
déplore déplore e le gouque le t
se bornese borneà fix à fix unee
aux nombaux nomb d'Afghare d'Afe
le Canadle Canaddoit acca doit .
PIERRE PPIERRE PL-HUS, dAUL-HUSC
CharlesbCharlesbrg - Hauourg - s
- Donc c- Donc ctait un 'était a
été lancété lancen l'airé en l'e
qui a étqui a étlancé poé lancée
de la de la litique.politique.a,
on parleon parle'êtres d'êtresu,
de familde famils, de geles, dei
nous ontnous ontés en  aidés en.
- Le min- Le mintre de listre dn
se défense défen mais n'd, maiss
plus loiplus loin.
SEAN FRASEAN FRAR, min. SER, mi,
RéfugiésRéfugiést Citoye et Cité
- Nous r- Nous rtons ferestons s
notre ennotre engement gagementr
au moinsau moins0 000 re 40 000s
afghans afghans  Canada au Canai
rapidemerapideme et en tnt et e.
- Le pri- Le priipal obsncipal e
le manqule manqud'itinére d'itis
et fiablet fiabl pour soes pour.
- Nous t- Nous titons leraitonss
jour et jour et it et avnuit eté
l'ensembl'ensemb de notrle de nu
mondial mondial ur livrepour lis
en touteen toutergence. urgence.
- Pendan- Pendance tempst ce ten
et Hakimet Hakime rappel se raps
souvenirsouvenirde la mis de lan
canadiencanadien en Afghne en A.
Et l'intEt l'intprète rerprète r
un jour un jour unir sesréunir s
et soeuret soeurici.s ici.
"J'esp "J'espre les rère les r,
je n'ai je n'ai cune idéaucune a
possiblepossiblemais je , mais s
espoir,"espoir,"it-il. dit-il.
En atte En atteant, Hakndant, m
a trouvéa trouvéne nouve une no.
"Pour m "Pour m et pouroi et p,
il fait il fait rtie de partie .
On célèOn célèe l'Actibre l'Acte
et Noëet Noëensemblel ensemble.
Je l'ai Je l'ai opté, maadopté,e
aussi, caussi, cst tout 'est tot
comme çacomme ça conclut", conc.
Ici Val Ici Valie Gamacérie Ga,
Radio-C Radio-Cada,